[Music]
we all know our time here is limited but
we don't know by how much are we better
off not knowing when we'll die or what a
countdown help us all to lead happier
and more fulfilling lives what if you
knew exactly when you were going to die
what would you change about the way you
live this is what if and here's what
would happen if you knew when you were
going to die it's not a cheery subject
not too many people like to talk about
it not too many people like to think
about it some people joke about it but
that doesn't make it any easier death
there I said it
it's scary but it also rouses our
curiosity we all know we're gonna go but
we don't know where we're going and we
don't know when these unknowns are the
source of a lot of anxiety but should
they be what if knowing the future date
and time of our deaths actually helped
us how should I say this
rest in peace despite the fact that a
lot of people around the world suffer
from thanatophobia a technical term for
the fear of dying
there are several compelling reasons why
knowing when you're going to die is
better than not knowing in a series of
research studies psychologists asked
people with terminal illnesses and
inmates on death row to reflect on life
knowing that there's would soon be over
they then asked a separate group of
people to imagine what it would be like
if they knew they were going to die in
every study those who knew they were
about to die spoke more positively about
life and death compared to those who
presumably had a lot longer to live the
people who didn't know when they were
going to die found it harder not to
think about the negatives
feelings of loss meaninglessness and
missing out on all the things they
didn't get to see or do but the group
who knew exactly how much time they had
left found peace in reflecting on their
life's experiences and accomplishments
they appreciated their family and close
friends and the happy memories that
accumulated over their lifetime but
imminent death isn't just a time to
reflect for many people it confirms that
we should all live life to the fullest
once we know how little time we actually
have left truisms like you only live
once wouldn't sound like cliches you'd
want to use your time effectively doing
the things that mattered most to you and
depending on your bucket list the sky is
the limit would you leap from the edge
of space or plunge to the deepest parts
of the ocean would you endeavor to see
as much of the world as possible would
you seek out new flavours or intense
thrills to remind you of what it means
to be alive or is life simpler than that
maybe you'd choose to spend more time
with family and close friends maybe you
tell someone special how they really
make you feel you complete the
possibilities and combinations are
endless and almost unique to every
person on this planet but you know that
some people would still strive to live
beyond their time it's estimated that
roughly 1,000 young women moved to
Hollywood every month to try their luck
at becoming a star too a lot of people
this might sound like an act of pure
naivete or glaring vanity but research
suggests that the drive for fame is a
little deeper than that for those who
have a hard time coping with their
mortality becoming famous or having a
legacy is comforting knowing that their
name and reputation will live on in the
world even after they're gone of course
there are also plenty of examples of
people who facing imminent death have
used their remaining time to champion
important issues and inspire positive
change
but what do you think you'd choose to
become an activist a star a daredevil or
at one with nature the important
takeaway is start living you don't need
to know how much time is left to start
thinking about what it is you want to do
and go out there and do it but if you
think knowing would help scientists have
had some success predicting the
probability of your death by looking at
various markers in your blood
ai is also getting good at determining
the length of your lifespan the idea
that we all die someday is undoubtedly
scary but as Edward Abbey once wrote the
fear of death follows from the fear of
life one who lives life fully is
prepared to die at any time
so start ticking off the items on your
bucket list remember that love and
kindness go a long way think of ways you
can make the world a better place and
take on the challenge make the most of
your time because life is short and
unpleasant as that may seem isn't it for
the best
well could you imagine what the world
would be like if nobody died that's a
story for another what if